well my friends there's been a terribly
tragic accident in russia where a
russian official who criticized putin's
invasion of ukraine
has been found dead after accidentally
falling out of a window in the very
hospital where he was receiving
treatment for an illness
it's just a terribly tragic accident
that absolutely no one believes is an
accident it's another one of these
bizarre situations reuters reports
top russian oil official dies after fall
from hospital window from a hospital
window
reveal maganov the chairman of russia's
second largest oil producer luke oil
died thursday earlier today after
falling from a hospital window in moscow
becoming the latest in a series of
businessmen to meet with sudden
unexplained deaths the sources confirmed
reports by several russian media that
the 67 year old plunged to his death in
unclear circumstances
two people who knew him well said it was
highly unlikely he committed suicide
another source close to the company said
there was belief inside luke oil
management that he killed himself but he
had not seen evidence or documents to
support that when moscow police were
asked are you investigating this as a
suspicious death they said well talk to
the investigative committee the
committee didn't say anything
luke oil said in a statement maganov
passed away
following a serious illness
well that's very different
uh you know you're sick in bed and you
want some fresh air you get up to open
the window to get some fresh air and you
trip over i don't know your iv line or a
banana peel and next thing you know
you fall out the window to your death
that doesn't sound right
several other senior executives with
ties to russia's energy industry
have died suddenly in uncle clear
circumstances in the past few months
the day after russia sent forces into
ukraine a gazprom executive was found
dead in his garage near saint petersburg
in april sergey protosenia
top manager of russia's largest
liquefied natural gas producer novatek
was found dead with his wife and
daughter in spain
in may russian media reported a former
luke oil manager alexander subiton was
found dead in a basement of a house
and the same month russian media said
vladislav avayev an ex-vice president of
gazprom bank was also found dead at a
moscow apartment with the bodies of his
wife and daughter
hmm
i don't know about that
unusual among russian companies luke oil
took a stand over moscow's intervention
in ukraine they expressed concern over
the tragic events and called for the
soonest possible end to armed conflict
ah
well that starts to get
a little suspicious doesn't it
now some of you might be wondering
why do these people
let's be honest why do they keep getting
killed in the same way doesn't that make
it too obvious well that's the point
it's not that they're out of ideas the
idea here is you send a message if
people really believed that these were
accidents
then the threat that you might get
killed even if you're powerful just for
opposing the putin regime
it doesn't come across it doesn't have
the power and the weight that it does
that's the whole point this
accident that always looks the same oh
you know what they shot themselves in
the back four times
they fell out of a window and then
stabbed themselves a dozen times right
you get the absurdity of it
the fact that it is so absurd is the
entire point
and it creates this environment where
some critics choose not to speak out
and um
it's putin's russia it's putin's russia
is what it is and
no tragic accident i think we can say
with almost complete and total certainty